[Música]
como todos los sábados beatriz salió de
su casa
dispuesta a lavar el carro como ya era
costumbre para iniciar la semana con su
coche limpio
eran las once y media de la mañana del
12 de enero
y beatriz no regreso a casa
en los periódicos se leía
mueren cuatro a manos de jóvenes en
motocicleta
en ese entonces yo trabajaba como
encargada del despacho del instituto de
jóvenes así que sí
ese día sentí muchísima vergüenza del
cargo que desempeñaba
era
una de las funcionarias públicas más
jóvenes en el estado preparada con
experiencia en el tema juvenil y sin
embargo no hubo una sola acción que yo
pudiera hacer para que esas dos personas
tomaran la vida de otras personas
inocentes
y que podía hacer yo como funcionaria
pública como concesionada pública y
joven para que estas dos personas
dejaran las armas y tomaron a su vez un
libro un instrumento que con sus manos
se sintieran dignos para llevar comida a
su mesa
en fin llegó el día del funeral me
acerqué a saludar a la persona a su
hermana a la hermana de beatriz que has
de ser una gran maestra y un excelente
ser humano es una persona a la que tuve
el honor de llamarle scouter durante
tres años de mi vida en mi formación
como scout
y me dio una de las lecciones de vida
más grandes que me hayan podido regalar
antes ella me dijo mori
no lo entiendo
pero lo acepto
la sencillez
la aceptación con la que ella me dijo
estas palabras me hizo darme cuenta de
lo valioso y de lo increíble que es el
no juzgar a las personas
yo sé que la historia de beatriz es como
la de muchas otras personas en méxico y
en tamaulipas sé que no es el único caso
en 2010 la mitad de los delitos
cometidos en méxico fueron por personas
jóvenes donde el 46.7 por ciento fueron
presuntamente cometidos por jóvenes
entre los 18 y los 29 años de edad el
60.5 por ciento entre los 18 y los 24
años de edad esto según unas cifras del
inegi y la verdad es que sí es
espeluznante y nos da miedo pero ahora
les quiero invitar a que vean un poco
las cifras de 2016 en tamaulipas según
el censo nacional donde el 56 punto 49
por ciento de los delitos cometidos en
el estado fueron perpetrados
presuntamente por personas jóvenes entre
18 y 29
y donde además
el 67 punto 38 fueron por personas de
entre 18 y 24 años
se nos ha catalogado como
como millennials como la generación z en
los que vienen debajo de los millennials
y somos considerados con etiquetas que
somos personas flojas que no nos
comprometemos que le tenemos miedo a la
responsabilidad y al compromiso
o me equivoco
donde obtener el placer fácil y de
manera inmediata sería lo que nos hace
movernos
y ahí lo entendí mientras me preparaba
para esta charla estaba investigando con
uno de los sociólogos chilenos que más
me gusta leer claudio duarte en uno de
sus artículos de que habla sobre
juventud o juventud es donde él empieza
a contraponer ciertas ideas que me
empezaron a dar vuelta a la cabeza y que
además me hicieron recordar una de las
frases que me dijo un gran amigo
guardáns y ya quien además le debo mucho
de la paz mental que el día de hoy
disfruto y me dijo moore y si quieres
cambiar tu vida tienes que cambiar tu
discurso y me flash yo flipé
porque mientras que claudio duarte nos
dice que cuando se impone y se socializa
un discurso es decir se conceptualiza la
juventud con etiquetas como las que hoy
damos a los millennials oa las personas
que vienen de la generación z que son
irresponsables etcétera desde una mirada
adulto centrista es decir desde la
visión desde la perspectiva de un adulto
entonces las personas jóvenes
en este caso las personas de las que se
esté hablando empiezan a definirse a sí
mismos y actuar según como dicen que
debo ser para entonces encajar en como
dicen que debo que soy
y sé que es un poco revuelto estoy
consciente de ello pero les voy a poner
el siguiente ejemplo
juan y pablo son dos jóvenes que están
por terminar la preparatoria ambos ven
trabajar a sus familiares a sus papás
día y noche en la maquiladora para poder
llevar el pan a la mesa y sin embargo
ven que apenas se alcanza para la comida
juan y pablo saben que si entran a la
maquiladora pues no van a tener tiempo
para nada más así que uno de sus amigos
les ofrece el salario que iban a ganar
en la maquiladora por pararse en la
esquina de la caída algo a observar y
avisar los movimientos que ellos
pudieran ver
ustedes que creen que vayan a decir juan
y pablo si toda su vida les hemos dicho
y han crecido con que si no a transas no
avanzas o que el fin justifica los
medios porque hay que vivir el aquí y el
ahora porque ya está carpe diem hashtag
soy mi propio jefe hashtag on estás
tomando el lugar
y si la risa es comiquísimo y suena
ridículo pero saben que al final de
cuentas no la llegamos a creer tanto
pero tanto tanto
como si estas etiquetas realmente fueran
ciertas
en fin
una de las realidades es que estas
etiquetas están constantemente en los
discursos de la sociedad lo mismo decía
de los baby boomers lo mismo decíamos de
la generación de la posguerra lo mismo
decimos de los millennials lo mismo
decimos de la generación zeta
no creen que ya basta de tanta etiqueta
no creen que es tiempo de cambiar el
discurso y si el contexto también llega
a ser parte de lo que nos hace crecer y
en esa parte de crecer nosotros como
jóvenes hemos estado creciendo con la
conectividad con el internet con la
tecnología las tecnologías en la palma
de nuestra mano literalmente
y entonces qué pasa empezamos a ver
innovación tecnológica cada vez mayor y
entonces un señor un profesor de harvard
en el 95 clayton christensen de la
universidad de harvard empieza a hablar
de la teoría de la innovación disruptiva
es decir estas tecnologías que apuntala
van a dejar obsoletos ciertas
tecnologías que ya estaban hechas para
entonces sí cambiar y ser completamente
diferente a aquello que nosotros
estábamos acostumbrados un gran ejemplo
de esto puede ser por ejemplo los discos
los cds alguien se acuerda los casettes
bueno y cómo fueron yendo hacia lo que
hoy conocemos como las usb
otra de las definiciones de disruptivo
de la disrupción se la debemos al
talento humano a la rama del talento
humano donde la disrupción viene a ser
como un cambio de paradigma donde la
persona que es un talento disruptivo
empieza a ver las la situación con otros
ojos empieza a ver la realidad de manera
distinta y en ese sentido puede llegar a
proponer soluciones diferentes que a lo
mejor no se habían ocurrido antes
es así y siendo así el caso que hablar
de juventudes disruptivas es hablar de
mirarnos no sólo como una etapa de la
vida en la que estamos aprendiendo o en
la que estamos buscando o esperando a
ser adultos es mirarnos y reconocernos
con nuestras habilidades con nuestros
conocimientos conscientes de los cambios
que podemos llegar a hacer pero también
conscientes de lo que podemos seguir
replicando desde nuestra trinchera
así que sí
ser de una juventud disruptiva es lo que
nos va a permitir cambiar aquello que
nos hace sentir dolor
algunos ejemplos de las personas que
para mí han sido juventudes disruptivas
es mala la llosa fácil una joven que no
imaginaba a su país sin que las mujeres
pudieran ser parte de la educación o
alejandra ocasio una diplomática
estadounidense congresista que está
cambiando y modificando y cuestionando
las formas de hacer política en eeuu o
que les digo de creta thunberg un
adolescente que está faltando a la
escuela para poder surgir la categoría
de crisis ambiental a nivel mundial lo
que me dicen de marcela brown
una joven victorense que no imagina
nuestras calles sin peatones y que nos
invita a caminar todo el tiempo en
ciudad victoria
y así como estos ejemplos podemos hablar
de muchos otros
se dice también que la disrupción se da
en el ser humano cuando las genera las
el contexto es de desconcierto e
incomodidad e incertidumbre
y corrijan mesino
pero si alguien sabe de incertidumbre de
incomodidad de dolor y de pérdidas
somos los tamaulipecos
pero nunca de rendirnos porque salimos
todos los días a la calle a trabajar
seguimos poniendo nuestros negocios
queremos hacer cosas diferentes por
nuestra ciudad he tenido la gran
oportunidad de viajar por muchos de los
municipios del estado y lo que he visto
me ha inspirado muchísimo más que
cualquier podcast libro de autoayuda
etcétera porque porque he visto
juventudes comprometidas con su
comunidad he visto personas jóvenes que
dejan realmente la piel en las causas
que les duelen
las causas que les afectan
y porque la verdad y lo que voy a decir
a continuación me compromete muchísimo
pero no hay en todo méxico juventudes
más resilientes que las tamaulipecas
porque hemos crecido entre balaceras
entre ajustes de cuentas y toques de
queda
y aquí estamos
y entregándonos por las causas que nos
duele
por supuesto que hago voy a ver todo lo
que hay que cambiar y por supuesto que
nos agobia a ver lo mucho que nos va a
costar hacer los cambios que se
necesitan
pero vale la pena
y tenemos que ser valientes
a veces el acto de mayor disrupción en
la vida de una persona puede ser el ser
fiel a sus principios y a sus valores y
mantenerse coherentes porque el fin no
justifica los medios
méxico tamaulipas no necesita a ti y a
mí pero no necesita disruptivos
juventud disruptiva porque hay más valor
en salir a la calle y sentirse seguro
que sentir seguridad porque hay tanques
militares en nuestras calles juventud
disruptiva porque en gobierno hay más
personas que políticos juventud
disruptiva porque no podemos seguir
dedicando pláticas a personas como
beatriz
que salieron de su casa para ya no
regresar
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]